Steve Levy is celebrating 25 years as a
sports center anchor first day with ESPN
was August 1st 1993 hosting the 11
o'clock show on Thursday with Keith
Oberman and Kenny main will drop by as
well a tribute to Steve's ESPN career
will be part of the show really well I
that's what it says yes it must be true
so what how are they paying tribute to
you I really I really don't know where's
my one shot by the way Dan where am I
looking you're looking down the camera
fine juice I'll get the camera fine
share the prompter is there's no
prompter you know we can't do this
without a prompter honestly all they
asked me Mike McQuaid our old pal came
to me and said you know what do you what
do you want to do and I said you know I
imagine if you think about my 25-year
career the top of the list unfortunately
you google me is you know is the bulging
thing Googler kids say you don't even do
discs I'm afraid of it man I'm still
afraid so you just do bulging thing it
was one letter was a little letter okay
and so okay but you're going to be
co-hosting with Oberman so I figured we
would show it and they asked me it'd be
funny if keith was there because he was
there the night of bulging discs whole
thing is your fault you know that right
I know okay I I had the night off okay
can we do the oral history of bulging
discs here okay all right so you take
the night off
yeah I took that you have a good excuse
like really was it the last second thing
I can't remember they think my my wife
may have had a baby all right so that's
important we gave you that okay so I
once again I tune in yeah and I tune in
and see Olbermann take his grind I think
he takes his glasses off is crying he's
laughing so hard and I go oh my god
Keith Keith just melted down and then
they go to you yeah and you guys can't
keep it together yeah okay so setup
bulging discs this is the last time
we're ever gonna bring this up good and
then we have the audio that we can play
and then this is it so this is three
years in I think so 96
there's my is my recollection of this
it's Maurice Hearst of the Patriots and
so you're off that night and it's still
the times I got to co-host with you and
or Keith
we're very very intimidating but this
was Monday night and this was a big deal
because we would welcome everyone who
watch Monday Night Football on ABC
we'd go to break after the games over
hey welcome those here this is
SportsCenter blah blah blah we go
through a rip of injuries from Sunday's
games and Maurice Hurst of the Patriots
is suffering from a bulging disc in his
neck and again it really wasn't the
prompters fault I typed it correctly
into the prompter and I make the mistake
and then I I really kept it together for
quite some time and we are in video of
career-ending injuries to other people
and then we start to lose it and Keith
is really no help and and I'm really
trying to keep it together and but the
behind the scenes story that I don't
think was told so Mike McQuaid we have a
Mike McQuaid was the producer of
SportsCenter at the time right now it
oversees all sports um so we there was a
figure-skating story to come out of this
which my guess is probably belong to
Keith he would do the next story it was
the death of a figure skater okay oh so
in our industry when a story goes away
we put it down later in the show we say
kill it you know so kill the figure
skater
right is is what McQuaid says meaning
we're not gonna do that story well that
everybody cracks up over again she's
already dead right you know so so so we
can't handle that the cameras are
shaking keith is doing his thing and
keith has the line which is you know
Steve do we have any video of that oh I
thought it was thank God we don't have
video wow those lines yeah and so
everybody loses it again I mean the
cameras a shaky you know and I Dan I
really thought I was gonna get fired I
really did it was such a big deal and
I'm walking out of the studio and I
people are carrying tapes you know under
both arms I had 50 voicemails by the
time I got back to my desk from
prominent national broadcaster who I've
never met before and and then I got a
call from Norby the next day and I
thought this was that you're fired call
so Norma is your boss yeah they had a
Sports Center right and he says hey
that's some of the funniest television
I've ever seen keep up the great work
and I swear to God to this day once a
month someone will approach me and say
hey you're the you're the bulging disc
guy and I'm like yeah cool okay so yeah
I've got to be known for something
here's how it played out that night and
now the agent for Hearst has come out
and said he will file a grievance
against the pay tenants that according
to NFL rules the club should not have
been able to release his client because
he was injured the agent claims that at
the request of the team Hearst has been
playing with a bulging disc in his neck
since the start of the season the
Patriots spokesperson declined comment
on the matter others that are banged up
from around the NFL Jeff Hostetler
reinterred his leverage downhill from
here oh there's more games status to be
addressed on Wednesday Giants
quarterback Dave round left in the
fourth quarter after having the wind
knocked out of him in the game against
the Eagles towards the Lions quarterback
is not bad though right nunnery you're
holding done it's sprained right there
yeah Jim Flanagan rolled into him status
now you're trouble
Eagles quarterback in the background you
said legs and the first half Sunday's
Eagles Giants game did not return he's
expected to be back Sunday against the
Redskins Mike Mamula is teammate
suffered a dislocated left shoulder he's
expecting this
[Music]
on this fine play running into the ends
up I play straight is right hamstring
status man there is nothing wrong with
these injuries bone in his lower left
leg
Francis out for the year my apologies at
the injured thank you other injuries
without the pretty pictures Strickland
need Jones the Cowboys leading tackler
groin mentoring the ankle sprain thanks
for your help
something wrong perhaps all right now
that a haven of college sportswear oh my
goodness yeah so it's fast forward to
were so old Maurice her son playing at
Michigan last year actually the last
couple of years and I had been begging
my producers like if we get the Michigan
blowout we saw a ton of Harbaugh in the
last few years and I've said you know we
had so we had it loaded and we finally
had begged my producer beau Garrett at
the time and he finally after Moe Hurst
jr. makes a sack says alright five let's
do it here we roll it in and the kicker
is Maurice Hurst jr. on Twitter tweets
at me and goes you know my mom never
told me about my dad bulging and there
you have it this yeah you're a good
sport
thanks man yeah you're good sport well
what was your first job in sport I got a
I was the Jets reporter WNBC radio in
New York and I again I always told I'm
the luckiest guys I never had to leave
home right and I was prepared to leave
home the Binghamton Rangers would not
hire me for seven grand a year and room
on the road with the bus driver and I
tried to get that job play-by-play Yeah
right out of us we go I tried to get it
and you know I was like fifth on the
list like couldn't believe it was really
bothered again the rooming with the bus
driver and my mom had an issue with that
at that point and again they still
didn't give me the job so um I had a
connection Dave Sims yeah Mike Breen
there was the Jets report and it was a
two-minute taped report out at Hofstra
the Jets trained and I made that my
full-time job right I mean I spent eight
hours in the media room at Hofstra for a
taters you know two minute piece every
day now you know maybe I got 50 bucks a
day or something like that but that's
kind of what we do that's that's how we
all did it you know that would leap I
was in the NFL man right you know coming
out of college even if it was two
minutes a day on a flamethrower of a
radio station so when that first day you
got tspn yeah what were you thinking uh
I was thinking wow you know I was such a
New York City person right and Here I am
in Bristol and I the night before my
first show I go it's a Tuesday night and
I go to the local movie theaters it's
unbelievable I am the only I am the
single only person in the theatre this
is no exaggeration and I think for sure
they're not gonna show it why would they
show it they'll give me my money back
I'll go about my business and what you
see you know I don't remember the movie
so I the guy on the glass Dan ready yeah
I'm ready and they and they showed the
movie but you know there was no there
was no easy starting place then right
espn2 hadn't started there was no ESPN
news no ESPN Radio's no calm obviously
none of that so when you started you
really started on SportsCenter and that
was you know obviously before LA that
was the 2:00 a.m. Eastern 30-minute show
and I'm amazed too we got every scoring
every imagine that we got every single
score in and now we'll do a 90-minute
Sunday night show and we get half the
games and maybe because we're doing so
many other things but I was definitely
nervous I looked at the wrong camera the
entire lead-in from my first show so
Ravich is the veteran of time I think
he's here three months before me yeah
and he welcomes me and in those days
when we started with a lead-in he did a
two-shot look down boom go to your
camera so I looked down on it don't go
to my camera so I did the whole lead and
on a two-shot with rabbits staring at me
and McQueen's in my you're going one you
know turn the waters one look right look
anywhere other than where you're looking
right now but I bid best seat in sports
man you know there are a lot of talent
there's a lot of talented people came
through there and it could be
intimidating it could be
very competitive a question it was
survival of the fittest
aside from bulging discs yeah you ever
have any like great moments or anything
that stood out so I I've been fortunate
right the hockey thing was was really
fortunate to me you know it's a fluke it
wasn't a skill I happened to be in the
right place at the right time done the
three longest televised games ever so
that became a thing right and again
there's nothing about that it's just
lucky to be in that right spot we went
to camp Arif John which was really cool
we took the show on the road for a week
with Stewart and Kenny and you know it
was at a time where it wasn't wasn't
politically charged it was like we
weren't about either side we were there
to try to comfort give a slice of
Americana to to the brave men and women
in uniform at the time and to see the
smiles on their faces for us being there
and the the the most awkward thing was
it's a it's a thank you fest right
they're thanking us for coming right and
we're like no no we're good we thank you
we're here for you to make them smile
and so we got there the first night and
they were lined up and they set up this
this giant hall and it was for an NFL
preseason game based on the time
difference it worked out perfectly and
they were just so happy for any kind of
normalcy and you know they had
non-alcoholic beer right and popcorn and
signs and cheering for their team
whatever was just I don't think I could
do anything else to the SBA that will
ever top that did you anchor with
everybody Berman myself Keith Stewart
yeah myself Kilbourne did you yea
Kilbourne sure but it it was
intimidating you mentioned that like you
know we all came and I tell people this
it takes a while it's like in sports you
know the game slows down the baseball
turns into a beach ball all that kind of
thing and then slows down for you it was
intimidating coming in we all want it to
be either Dan or Keith and then you
tried to figure out okay well I got a
shot at this but I can't be that and you
try to emulate a style and I think I
fell into that trap too and then after a
while you figure out who you are who
you're gonna be and then guys are still
coming
now and gals you know people are still
coming in now and trying to be hey I
want I want to do it like Kenny main
does you know what I mean and you can't
and and after a while you figure out hey
this is what you're good at
I'm still trying to figure out exactly
what my style is but maybe that is my
style there's sort of no style it try to
get the score right you know I had a
hard time with that of trying to figure
out who I was and it may you know for
the audience they may it may sound
foreign they may go well just be
yourself it's the hardest thing because
you don't really know who you are and I
was one thing when I first got there I
was very serious about it
and then all of a sudden when Overman
came in he said why don't you act the
way you do off the air on the air and as
simple as it sounds I was like I added
this epiphany marlott okay
right like I all right it was I waited
for somebody to say it's it's okay to
have fun here and then all of a sudden
we had a little too much fun but we were
also like it got competitive with the
late-night Sports Center and then the
earlier Sports Center this six o'clock
with Bob Lee and Charley Steiner and
Robin Roberts and then you know they're
comparing ratings and now it got to be
like serious stuff and I was thinking
wow this is a tough enough job right now
I've got almost infighting here or
competition and management did nothing
to dispel that you know so it was one of
those where you're going
alright let me see it Mike surviving 18
years and I was lucky to survive 18
probably should have survived like 15
but we were in the building all 18 like
you know you didn't do any play-by-play
no as I recall so really even studio on
the road for the big event I was there
fright yeah I was always there right and
always at 11:00 d'jever I was six I did
six the last three years all right yeah
I had your own show right thanks for
watching I made at the Dan Patrick show
at six yeah ratings quit but I do I know
but I didn't like the six because I love
that frenetic feel of game just ended I
mean there are times I tell people where
you're on camera and you're gonna you're
doing a lead-in
yeah and you got some 23 year old
production assistant who's right over
here off camera ready to hand you the
shots yes of
your highlight yes so I haven't even
seen it so it could be a bucks were in
Cleveland tonight and we got the
highlights and I would reach out with my
left hand grab it and then turn it
around and then I go okay and you would
be doing the highlights live at the time
everybody's watching them and you're
just begging you're in essence praying
there's not a name that you don't
recognize that you can't pronounce right
hockey we get the boy yeah Nicolai
Habibullah
yes with a KUB Beulah I went exactly
yeah so first go-round and then you know
I have somebody says I should have give
you you know the you know phonetic
spelling I'm sorry
nikka like a bib Yulin and I think he
was just called up and I'm like oh this
poor guy his SportsCenter moment I
called him Capulet the beauty is
everybody else they called him the right
way because that's what they would think
it was but the shows really changed you
know the biggest change is Dan is you're
an essence allowed to root for your team
it openly on the air and that that's
been a big change we've become or been
allowed to become more like a fan you
know openly rooting for your team well
it's it's by design I don't I don't know
where it turned my thinker I think
Berman would always root for the Buffalo
Bills in the San Francisco 49ers right
Stewart made no secret of the fact that
he was rooting for North Carolina right
van Pelt with Maryland but then there
was really nothing to root for and Linda
with every New York team Linda Cohen
with every New York team I never I I
shed my allegiance when I got there I
tried to play it straight to I thought
that was our job right and and then I
was like well ladies saying I can't be
the only person on the air who doesn't
have a rooting interest you know we're
not raised as impartial journalist as
kids we all come up having diehard you
know diehard of certain teams but I
didn't think that was my job and now I'm
like you know what if everybody's gonna
do it then I'm you know J ETS Jets Jets
Jets let's go thank you for the darn old
thing by the way you're welcome that
yeah I got him into camp you know how do
you feel about that that's your that's
your Savior I'm very excited about it
you are I thought that was a big whoop
you're not well no I I just because it's
the Jets oh well we could mess anything
yes you can you could screw up an anvil
but I thought it fell right in our laps
our that's tell jet slap yeah
it never never breaks the Jets way and I
thought this time it did break the the
Jets way darling what I wasn't thought
the first choice alone and I saw a lot
of them in college too
no that's right you're mr. play-by-play
College play-by-play and you're doing
the Broncos coming up Prince he's
excited about that he's going
coast-to-coast to a preseason he is okay
yeah he's going out to watch the Broncos
preseason
then and so you're gonna do that yeah
first flight out Sally Olga's 80th for
the Bears at the Broncos and flying home
Sunday he will be there all four
preseason games that leaves is doing
with Brian Griese yeah you have Todd in
the booth I was saying we'll definitely
get him on television he's gonna wear
he's got some cool a throwback jersey
yeah I told him my son's gonna be
running a Steve Atwater old-school
Jersey and I'm gonna be wearing a 77
Carl Mecklenburg jerseys we throw me you
know a cutaway shot going a break or
something when the starters come out you
know something like that
well he was invited by a bond Miller to
be in the parade on one of the floats
hang on are we joking now in serious
what any past because we said what are
you tied up because it was gonna just be
me and I felt like if I if I didn't have
my son with me wouldn't be as special to
just for just to be me on the float and
building yourself
I think he would have understood at the
moment I just felt like it we just
wouldn't be right because we watched so
many games together we scream and yell
petit and respect and then he passed up
on Super Bowl tickets again because I
was gonna just be me wandering around by
myself without a second ticket tried
yeah I mean I got him on the float the
actual float with von Miller if it wears
glasses yes for thought about his class
as you got to say one thing to this day
cuz I worked with Steve at WFAN almost
30 years ago in 1990 and I was just
learning how to edit tape and you know
splice things are the things that you
used to do before there was any kind of
technology and I hung levy out to dry
one Sunday night he was very
understanding about it he saw how
nervous I was cuz I was just getting
started
WBAL Sunday night we carried this Sunday
night baseball games and he was didn't
know in the newsroom and he's doing he's
doing his thing and he's getting ready
to do a sports cast and I thought what I
had was
the homerun that just happened we always
would call card up the audio of homeruns
or big plays and then he would throw two
signals at one one Orioles Blue Jays and
the Orioles actually just made it three
to one
here's how it sounded on WBAL silence I
obviously whatever I did or didn't do it
with what I thought was recorded I
didn't get a chance to listen to it back
and I was in a big rush to get it to our
screwed me to our producer Gillian the
producer screaming he couldn't have been
more professional he saw that you know I
was nervous I thought this was my last
day at FA n and he made me feel better
and let it go but that was just a
horrible moment cuz it's on the speakers
all over the news room on the ceiling
everywhere and we're waiting to hear
this call of a Ripken two-run home and I
made it 3-1 in the fourth and silence
Paulie you got a leave you story I sure
do Steve out remember this mm I just
started working at ESPN I was working
NFL on ESPN Radio yep which Steve kind
of invented back at WFAN in the 90s
where you throw it to reporters at all
different sites rapid-fire so Levy was
Steve you were filling in I was only
about two months of the job and we're
segment one and you go to me you go
we're gonna go to Oakland then we're
gonna go to Jacksonville we're gonna
indeed we're gonna Houston in Denver
rapid fire back around I go again you
stay with me brother you gotta stay with
me stay with me brother stay with me
that's a line stay with me yeah Steve is
celebrating 25 years Thursday night it's
must-see TV there's just not enough room
it's it's you and Oberman and Kenny main
how about all is there an after-party
VIP red carpet yeah what do you got in
Bristol on Thursday night there's not
much across even the McDonald's is
closed across the street it has come on
you knew this right I haven't been up
there yeah do you know how many
McDonald's close like they never ever
closed right they never go out of
business and McDonald's ever you know we
had all the PAS and the interns when
they lived on that stuff some of the
anchors but we have a great cafeteria
there yes we do now
yeah but they say they fenced in the the
compound there and then you couldn't
easily walk across the street so
McDonald's closed yeah Wow
even with the new great quarter pounders
yeah remember the Hall of Shame yes the
Hall of Fame bar we yes whoo yep yeah
had fun there
Kendal's Kendall's on route 10
yeah yeah quick is that that Queen
Street what's the Queen Street or Route
10 or is that is that is one of the same
yeah Kendal's yep oh good times row and
we would get there and you'd have about
like 32 minutes to drink before they
closed up so you would you know try to
have a like three beers in 32 minutes
the occasional shot to just to kick it
off to get it going and it was all ESPN
I could be no regular customer the ball
would be totally empty until that moment
it would be so sad if there were 30
people coming in I know well yeah
Kendal's and we had fun and then they
might keep it open and then we've cut
off all the lights right and then we
would have to be quiet
oh we were good tippers we were weren't
oh well you might have been is your
Steve Levy 25 years at the mothership
Thursday night with Keith Olbermann
Kenny maim and a tribute to Steve's
career will be part of the show it's
great seeing you leaves Congrats thanks
for having me happy for you for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]